I love I love the fact that weed is
legal in California and I love these
recreational here I will say the one
thing I don't like I don't like that you
behave teen and get your medical license
I think issue 21 across the board mostly
because I have older kids and I ran into
my sons in my weight story I walked in
and I go hey man and he goes hey hey
what are you doing here he goes I think
the same thing you're doing here and
then he put his wallet away angle what
are you doing he goes well you hear
you're fine right I think we didn't just
leave your little league game man you
know what I mean this isn't Baskin
Robbins I'm not buying you three scoops
ROG cush [ __ ] this works is he
here he's here okay so one night I had
my now I will tell you my wife said how
do you know he stole
know anybody who does antics knows
exactly how many [ __ ] bars are in
that bottle at your house and right now
I give you do drugs and someone move
something you're like who the [ __ ] move
that milligram dose I know so I'm like
maybe I'll just go down maybe I'll just
go down and see if he's high or if they
stay together so I go down into his room
open the door and he's shirtless on this
bed doing this
[Applause]
huh huh what are you doing man he goes
just trying to figure something out
[Music]
know what he goes oh honey try me and he
was like okay was gonna sound crazy and
I got try me he goes move the first
thing I need to know is can you hear
this
[Music]
I said I cannot he goes the one that you
can't help me
so his head's been down this whole time
and I go to I go hey man stop for a
second stop it just inside and you know
when you're that high and you're doing
something this weird for all he knows
like he thinks he's saving the world so
I can just stop for a second and he
looks up just like this like Jack
Nicholson had just been dumped in that
vat of chemicals in Batman you know I
mean I don't know how's he gonna use
where do you go what are you doing he
was like you know just hey you know what
I got I got you
I own ethical is a food we did that
sounds delicious
I'd like to try one of those someday
I'll bet you would oh you didn't steal
one miles you know at all I know you
didn't steal it he was annoyed and I
didn't steal it and then I looked down
his trash can and the [ __ ] wrapper is
right there honey go what's that he goes
oh I stole that I stole your attaboys
and he goes I'm so glad you saw that
wrapper up so high I can't fake it
anymore
oh he's so dumb